- Like I said today, it's
not happening tomorrow.
- [Man] Yeah, yeah.
- But as soon as they fucking understand
how fast it is and as soon as it gets good
and as soon as it's...
What Google doesn't do now
that Voice is gonna do,
is it's gonna respond.
How about the tone of your voice?
- [Man] I know.
That's what Jeff was saying
about intention and all that.
- A hundred percent?
We're gonna be able to,
like, if I hung out with
him every single day,
I would know his tone of voice.
Your device is gonna know that.
So when he's searching for something,
it's gonna understand the context.
- [Man] Yeah, that's wild.
- It's much...
- [Man] Based on everything.
Your finances, everything.
- If you took your
grandparents when they were 20
and showed them today with all this shit,
they'd be like what the fuck?
And that's where people get caught.
And in 10 years, it's like the speed
of what's happened the last 40 years.
Because it's exponential speed.
- [Man] Yeah, yeah.
- So people think they're
gonna be a player.
(upbeat music)
What's up guys?
Rainy Tuesday here, late May, 2018.
VoiceCon
in the building.
Our first VoiceCon thrown by VaynerMedia,
VaynerExperience, Ken Garcia,
Atmo, the rest of the team.
I'm just super excited about it.
Very much feel like Voice
is where social media
was in 2006 and 7.
I want to put a flag in
the ground in events,
I think event marketing in
general, for all of you watching,
is an amazing place to establish a brand.
So that's what we're doing here.
You've never thought about
what your business sounds like.
Sitting here and realizing, oh shit,
I'm gonna have to have a
conversation with my dad Sasha
about what's the voice of
Wine Library sound like
is a pretty exciting kind of conversation
just out of humor for me as a human.
(audience laughs)
But I think it's very important,
especially, it's just
something we don't think about.
It's something that we could
have never thought about.
The same way that we could
have never thought about
how important a logo was for social
or things of that nature or your tagline
or things of that nature.
You know, how unbelievably important
over the next decade or two,
what your brand sounds like
is actually going to be
a variable of success.
An incredible list of speakers,
wonderful content.
I'm excited about it in general.
It's just an exciting day.
A day I'll definitely look back on
in seven to 12 years.
I'll reference, you know,
this is a great day because
we'll probably reference
it six, seven, eight, nine years from now.
We can use the footage here
and keep inter stenciling it
into DailyVee 2013.
Not the year, episode 2,013.
Figuring out Voice
is like an obsession of mine,
because I think it's
what's going to happen
over the next decade.
- Yeah, well, it's already happening.
That's the thing about this stuff,
people are just waking up,
but it's sort of like, you're behind.
- [Man] Yeah, absolutely.
- About 35, raise your hands.
Perfect.
So youngsters, you've gotta hear this.
Back when we were kids.
(audience laughs)
If you wanted to meet your
friend somewhere in public,
it went down like this.
You'd have to tell them in school that day
that you were meeting at 4:15
and you had to meet by
the big water fountain
at the fuckin' mall.
(audience laughs)
But here's where it gets gnarly.
If for some weird reason
your mom was running late
and you got there at 4:25,
there was a 50/50 chance
that the person gave up
and you never saw them.
(audience laughs)
It's just remarkable how in
a very short period of time,
that seems ludicrous because of this.
The biggest framework that
I'm looking for everybody
to come away with this is to
dream and imagine and project
how big of a deal Voice is going to be.
Backseat Answers, take seven.
Well, four, actually.
- [Interviewer] Question
from athletic_assault.
- Yeah?
- [Interviewer] How did you
start your speaking career?
And I'll add onto it,
how would you recommend someone starting?
- Sure, I randomly got an email that said,
hey, can you speak at
an internet conference?
I said sure.
I went there and fucking slayed the stage
and never looked back.
The way I would recommend doing it,
last night I said,
and I'm sure D Rock can clip this for you,
I told Jessie, an incredible artist,
don't be fancy until you're fancy.
Way too many people at speaking
are fancy before they're fancy.
They wanna get paid,
they wanna be a headliner.
If you want to speak, you
need to speak for free.
Like, Jerry Seinfeld and Dave Chappelle,
these people didn't go to
play Radio City and get like.
The complete lack of
people willing to eat shit
to win the game.
You want to be a public
speaker and make money
and do that whole game?
Great, go on social media
and event pages
and see events that are
going on in your general area
and offer to speak for free.
Fancy fucker.
And be good at it and do it 50 times.
I got paid for the first one,
but after that, once I got the drug of it,
I think I spoke for free
for 38 of the next 40.
- [Interviewer] How many
speeches do you think you did
before the Web 2.0 one,
the one that popped?
- 2009.
2009,
2007.
Probably...
Probably
12 to 15.
So think about that.
That's the one that popped,
clip it here.
Everybody had time.
Stop watching fucking Lost.
That smurfin' up stuff is the best.
And then I still went
on to do 20 for free.
And I'm still willing to do it for free
even though I get paid 150 to
200,000 dollars a speech now.
If it's strategic, I'll do it for free.
Don't be fancy until you're fancy.
I can't wait to see in Toronto.
I can't wait to be back, Melissa.
Somebody put your phone
number in, I'm gonna call you.
Let's go.
Phone numbers here in Facebook Live.
'Cause they're going way
too fast up there for me.
I'm also with First in Line, loving it.
First in Line's amazing.
Just giving away free shit.
Free sneakers, free time.
Fuckin' just tough to
not love First in Line.
If you are not part of First in Line,
you're making a huge fuckin' mistake.
Hit me up on Facebook Messenger right now
and get the auto reply from the AI bot
and fill out the form.
(phone beeping)
You know?
And watch awfully good
things happen happen
to your life.
(phone rings)
I'll come back, Jason, to VoiceCon,
I'll be right back.
I had to do something for the office.
(phone rings)
Let's go, brain hammer.
- [Voice On Phone] Hello?
- Lyle?
- [Lyle] Yes, hello.
- What up brother, it's Gary V.
- [Lyle] Oh, man, Gary.
What's going on, man?
I didn't expect this.
- Well, you put your fucking
phone number into Facebook.
What do you think's gonna happen?
- [Lyle] Look, you've got
millions of followers, man.
- I get it, brother.
- [Lyle] There's a one
in a million messages.
- I get it.
How are you, what can I answer for you?
- [Lyle] It's a been
bad, bad freaking day.
My wife's just got her job cut.
- Fuck.
- [Lyle] Today.
- I'm sorry.
- [Lyle] Yeah, after
working for non-profit,
helping special needs kids.
Bad boss got rid of her.
- I'm so sorry, man.
- [Lyle] So it's been a tough day.
- What does she do?
- [Lyle] I really, I really...
What's she do?
- Yeah, what is she good at?
- [Lyle] She's administrative,
a fantastic administrative assistant.
- Well you know, we're hiring
some of those at Vayner.
You want to send her resume to me ASAP?
- [Lyle] I would love to.
- Do it right now.
- [Lyle] Alright, we'll do that.
But yeah, we need, like, yeah.
I need to move forward in my life,
you know what I'm saying?
- I get it, brother.
You're doing your art and all that shit.
- [Lyle] Yeah, that's tough to get going.
- Of course.
- [Lyle] It's just...
The motivation and everything you give up,
it's just amazing and
sometimes life kicks you down
and you're just trying
to pull yourself back up.
That goes for almost everybody.
- Lyle, you know what I want to do?
'Cause I got real love for you,
you've been a part of this
community for a long time.
You're gonna send me your wife's resume.
Tyler's right in here,
he's gonna look for that.
We'll get that in motion.
I'll get her over to
Claude and our hiring team.
- [Lyle] I appreciate it.
- 'Cause we are doing admin stuff.
So I'll get her in here ASAP.
But I want to do something else.
I really like the art that you've made.
I know you've made that piece for my dad
which I liked.
I'm gonna--
- [Lyle] I did one for you.
- I'm aware of that.
- [Lyle] For your uncle.
- I'm aware, I saw it.
I saw it in his social.
Here's what I wanna do.
I want to buy from you,
for a couple hundred bucks a piece,
five pieces for
some of my homies
in the hiphop world who
I'm doing some stuff with.
I'm gonna have Tyler connect with you.
So just send me an email
with your wife's resume
and you're gonna email me an invoice
for five sketches at 300 bucks a pop,
$1,500 and he'll tell you.
- [Lyle] I appreciate that.
- And he's gonna tell you
who to make them of, okay?
- [Lyle] Wow, man, I really appreciate it.
This means everything to me right now.
- My pleasure, brother.
This is how life works, man.
You know, the fuckin' odds
of me having this down time
to go on Facebook Live,
the odds of me picking
your phone out of that whole stream
and the odds of it being
the day with what's going on
and the odds of me working on this thing
that makes me inspired
to make these sketches
for these people and I'm also gonna twist
their arm a little bit
and make sure they tag you
in their story when they post it.
And maybe this can be the
beginning of the beginning.
- [Lyle] I really appreciate it, man.
I'm all choked up right now.
- No worries, man.
Don't fuck up the email to Tyler.
'Cause then it all fuckin'
goes to zero.
- [Lyle] I won't.
I'm gonna do that right now.
- Alright, brother, I
love you, have a good day.
- [Lyle] I love you too, man.
I appreciate it, thanks.
- Doing the right thing
is the right thing, babin.
- I wish I had a question for you,
but I know you're gonna tell
me to just fuckin' work.
(Gary laughs)
So I just want to tell you,
a year and a half ago I was
going through a hard time
and I started listening to you
and a couple of other dudes.
You guys helped me out along the way.
So from the bottom of my heart,
I just want to tell you thank you.
And I love you.
- Thank you, brother.
- I'll admit it.
I'm gonna work my ass off for you.
- It's always the answer.
- Absolutely.
- But the only way you
can fuckin' work hard
is if you actually like it.
- Oh yeah.
- The problem is people do things
that they think are gonna make them money,
but they don't like it and
then they can't work hard
'cause they don't like it
and then you can't make the money
if you don't work hard.
It's a fucking vicious cycle.
- [Gary Voiceover] The
point of view on this
is the word "convince"
scares the shit out of me.
I've spent my whole
career talking about stuff
that most people don't believe at the time
that I start talking about it.
And I have found through the last 25 years
that I'm way better off just continuing
to talk about it and
not convincing people,
but letting the market
force them into my world.
You would be way better off
if you decide to do something here
to go to everybody and
focus on the three people
of 418 that do it with you
and do it amazing for
them than to sit there
and try to convince people
that are never gonna go there.
Convincing the unconvinceable
is just a terrible strategy
that I see so many people
spending their time with.
I sometimes go into a
pitch and I'm fundamentally
checked out within the first 10 minutes.
I'm like, this is over.
We're here to check a box that they wanted
somebody innovative to be here.
They're out.
And what's crazy I'm not
fuckin' mad at this business.
I signed up for this.
I just am not emotional
about convincing people.
I am thrilled to just stay alive
until it happens and then
look at them and say,
I fuckin' told you, dick.
(upbeat music)